good morning John so a little while ago
I went on Google and I was going to ask
the question what's the difference
between something and something but I
didn't get that bar because I noticed
how interesting all the questions other
people were asking were having forgot
completely what I was going to ask
Google instead today I'm just going to
answer all of the questions other people
are asking for every letter of the
alphabet starting with a thousand Ravens
are two completely different species
there's a bunch of them and they're
acting and sounding pretty annoying
those are crows there's one or two of
them and you think is that a cat because
it's huge
that's a rave baking soda is the
chemical sodium bicarbonate it produces
carbon dioxide when mixed with an acid
that carbon dioxide fluffs up baked
goods baking powder is baking soda with
the acid or tea mixed in so I have to do
is add water in the u.s. a college is a
school that teaches only the years
directly after secondary education a
university has some graduate school
components to make things extra
confusing both colleges and universities
can contain other colleges services
Supper is a really interesting
linguistic thing that happened
apparently Supper means a different
thing to everyone English people and
things are from England which is a
country inside the country of the United
Kingdom British people and things
technically are anything from the United
Kingdom so Northern Irish people Welsh
people Scottish people all British
though they probably don't wanna be gone
that air infer are scientifically the
exact same thing Hulu Plus costs more
and you can watch it on your TV or your
mobile device there's also very slightly
more content on Hulu Plus if I see is
the kind of value edition of the iPhone
the camera and the processor and the
design are all a little bit less fancy
jelly is jelly juice and jam is jellied
fruit pulp so Jam is a little bit softer
as with anything in linguistics this is
surprisingly complicated but both kun
and son are Japanese honorific suffixes
they're added to the end of names to
show respect song is used between equals
while kun is used in reference to
someone junior to you generally a male
person LCD is the kind of display
technology LED is the kind of
backlighting the TV ads they have
nothing to do with each other in these
days most TVs are LCD display backlit by
led I mean biologically there's very
little difference between you and me
humans are all very very similar to each
other I have no idea what nos and sonn
are I looked it up and in something to
do with IT infrastructure and sorry out
of my depth their subjective statements
are based in opinion objective
statements are based in fact the source
one makes no sense so I'm gonna skip it
prisons are where you go when you've
been convicted of a crime and sentenced
to serve time
jails are where you go when you've just
been detained or have been arrested and
are awaiting trial
you can also end up in a jail if you've
been convicted but your sentence isn't
very long with full and quick formats
will wipe all the data off your hard
drive but only the full format will
rebuild the file structures that the
drive itself uses to store the files and
scan for bad sectors on the drive both
Rangers and Green Berets are special
operations forces in the Army any
recruit can apply to be a ranger but
only soldiers who've been in the Army
for at least three years can apply to be
a Green Beret Green Berets must also
speak at least two languages
Judy's performed by both groups though
are similar schedules the type of
whiskey it's it's Scotch meaning that
it's made in Scotland to either means
excessively or also to it's just for all
the other times unless you mean to as
far as I can tell uber and lyft a pretty
much the same thing they're both
newfangled ways to get taxis and people
seem surprisingly excited about both
considering that taxis will be mostly
driven by robots in ten years green
cards give the right to permanently live
and work in the US while visas only
temporarily give you that right Trina
white asparagus at the same plant but
white asparagus has dirt piled on top of
it while it's growing so that it's never
exposed to light under all that dirt it
doesn't produce chlorophyll and it
doesn't need the structures necessary to
stand up on its own so it's milder in
flavor and softer in texture x64 is the
64-bit CPU architecture for Windows 7
that works on newer machines while x86
is the older 32-bit design green and
yellow zucchini at different colors and
finally at zucchini is a squash John I
hope this video was educational for you
and for everybody else I'll see you on
Tuesday
I made this script publicly available
before I made this video as part of the
nerdfighter online video workshop so
people have already uploaded their
versions of this video on their channels
before I did which is weird so far the
Nov W is just very cool thanks to
everyone who's been doing performances
and edits and script writing and
especially to people who've been
constructively critiquing those
performances and edits and scripts if
you'd like to learn more about the Nov W
there's a link in the description